et voici maintenant l'invité des cinq
dernières minutes et s'est invité ses
marines à ce bon jour on est vraiment
ravis de vous recevoir sur le plateau du
13 heures de france 2 on vous reçoit
pour tellement de choses qu'on ne sait
plus par quoi commencer ya d'abord le
ceser que vous avez reçu il ya quelques
semaines pour de la meilleure actrice
pour lesdites chatterley ensuite un vrai
pari au théâtre puisque vous jouez dans
le partage de midi de claudel à la
comédie française
et puis vous étiez à cannes vous aussi
vous êtes justement monté sur ce fameux
tapis rouge on vient de voir ce qu'il ya
deux jours je crois alors pour le
scaphandre et le papillon le film de
schnabel qui a beaucoup ému d'ailleurs
le public et les critiques à cannes
première question toute simple comment
vous résister à tout ça en même temps
en fait je le théâtre me sauve à ce
niveau là parce que je suis vraiment je
travaille tous les deux trois soir à la
comédie-française en alternance dont je
me remets en question tout le temps dont
je suis absolument dans le travail
alors je peux partir un jour 2 pour kanu
ou venir ici parler de lady chatterley
ou quoi mais mais je suis replongé dans
le travail immédiatement donc ça c'est
un garde-fou alors justement on va
parler de ce césar de la meilleure
actrice pour lesdites 7e relais
j'imagine que ça a été une divine
surprise ce qu'on l'a dit le tournage a
été particulièrement difficile
oui oui on ne savait pas si le film se
terminerait et nie même s'il sortirait
parce qu'il n'y avait pas du tout
d'argent et des problèmes de production
tout le temps donc ça a été une divine
surprise pour moi pour toute l'équipe
pour pascale ferran et est en fait le
film n'a pas cessé d'être à l'affiché
depuis le 1er novembre
le dvd vient de sortir et puis il est
vendu dans le monde entier donc c'est
une histoire
est ce que ça a changé quelque chose
dans votre vie on imagine que oui que
vous avez eu de nombreuses propositions
après ce césar que beaucoup de au
cinéaste vous ont contacté quand même
oui mais en fait c'est pas vraiment le
ceser c'est surtout le film s'est
adressé au moment de la sortie du film
que nous impressionnait longues robes
aux professionnels oui oui et après le
césar est venu
également couronné le tout mais mais le
film a eu un impact très fort sur les
gens de la profession
pour moi en tout cas oui et comment vous
l'avez ressenti parce qu on vous sent
très calme plutôt même réserver parfois
par rapport à cette profession
ça a été un bonheur de voir que tout à
coup on s'est intéressé à vous vous êtes
un peu méfiante aussi par rapport à ça
non non ça a été un bonheur ça fait
quelques années que je travaille dont je
peux profiter de ça et je sais que c'est
pas toujours comme ça donc je j'en
profite vous tous vous tourner au cinéma
vous allez tourner de plus en plus votre
premier amour c'était vraiment théâtre
on peut le dire
là vous reprenez le partage de midi de
claudel donc à la comédie française
c'est un rôle que vous aviez vraiment
envie de jouer c'était une pièce qui
vous donnait vraiment envie il n'avait
pas particulièrement envie parce que je
pense que le plus important c'est d'être
choisi surtout par metteur en scène je
préfère pas avoir des rôles en fait pas
si c'est la vision du metteur en scène
qui va qui va donner là vraiment
l'intérêt du rôle donc là c'était yves
bonnet et c'était c'était incroyable
parce que dans ta mère l'avait joué
tranquillement opération que j'allais
vous poser est donc c'était je pense que
je me serais jamais autorisé de vouloir
jouer ce rôle qui avait été très
emblématique pour elle à votre maman
celle où 2001 michael tout le monde ne
le sait pas forcément c'était en 1975
avec vitesse une mise en scène de
vitesse et vous trente ans après vous
remonter sur les planches avec une
appréhension franchement vous l'aviez
vous ne l'aviez pas vu le jeu n'avait
pas vu donc je pense que l'appréhension
était était relative à la difficulté du
rôle est ce que c'est la première fois
que j'ai un rôle aussi important et et
aussi parce que je viens de rentrer à la
comédie française et que c'est une salle
très impressionnante
elle est venu vous voir j'imagine oui
elle est venue elle est alors elles
étaient contents et les plus soulagée
elle a trouvé ça beau et elle m'a dit je
suis une spectatrice très difficile
parce qu'elle était très amoureuse de
son travail avec antoine vitez
elle a trouvé le spectacle
incroyablement moderne et est accessible
aussi alors dernière chose vous avez
joué dans le scaphandre et le papillon
qui est un film manifestement
extrêmement émouvant très bien reçu à
cannes j'ai l'impression que ça a été
très émouvant aussi pour pour toute la
troupe de comédiens qui a participé à ce
film oui parce que c'est une histoire
vraie parce qu'en plus à cannes y avait
peut-être la rappeler c'est celle de
jean dominique de genre de niveau
qui a été atteint du syndrome orge et
lost in syndrom allah est en fait il a
écrit un livre seulement par le
clignement de son oeil avec un système
d'alphabet et de cligner pour arrêter
sur chaque lettre et il a écrit un livre
autobiographique sur ce qu'il était en
train de vivre est l adaptation ce livre
est donc les on est tous très très
investi dans le fait de transmettre
cette chose qui lui est arrivé et qu'il
avait envie de transmettre en plus et on
vous a senti rang vous a vu à cannes on
vous a sont utiles pardon vous a senti
tous vraiment très très investis par ce
film parle envie de transmettre cette
expérience
oui c'est vrai mais en plus parce qu'on
était très heureux de du film en
lui-même c'est un team très poétique
très très coloré très beau très fort
plein de vie c'est c'est eh je pense
qu'on était vraiment heureux de faire
partie de l'équipe et est d'avoir été
choisi parce nabeul qui est vraiment un
artiste baignait en tout cas merci
marina hands est revenu sur de notre
plateau je rappelle donc que vous jouez
le partage de midi de paul claudel à la
comédie française c'est jusqu'en
septembre
lady chatterley sort donc vient de
sortir en dvd
oui et puis et le scaphandre et le
papillon est sorti hier dans toutes les
bonnes salles de cinéma merci encore
mais retient c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de m'avoir suivi tout de
suite